ce lundi 27 juin les deux derniers
huitièmes de finale de l'euro opposés
l'italie à l'espagne et l'angleterre à
l'islande de rencontres qui ont attiré
les parieurs peuvent et l'angleterre et
puis italie espagne de faire annuler
donc en fait pour que l'on parie pas
s'il faut que l'angleterre va y gagne
enfin qui est match nul ou victoire de
l'islande où l'angleterre ne gagne pas
par plus de deux buts d'écart tu vois là
du coup j'ai misé 100 ça me rapporte
récents 40 448 choix j'ai jusqu'au
d'agde année sans eau à peu près de 60
euros le chiffre d'affaires de ce bureau
de tabac a augmenté de 3% grâce à l'euro
deux constats beaucoup de vainqueurs
pour le match italie belgique
en revanche de nombreux perdants pour
les rencontres du portugal
ça dépend des matches je veux jouer à
200 euros
oh moi c'est 5 euros le match pas plus
chez pat farmer noomiz et combien en
moyenne par match sa photo dans sept
autres établissements les paris sportifs
n'ont pas eu le succès attendu
les paris sont un peu moins nombreux
peut-être aussi par rapport à l'euro à
et ses effets de surprise qu'il ya eu
vingt équipes est l'une des surprises
c'est la qualification d islande et aux
dépens des anglais qu'envoyer l'islande
hier est à 8 alors que
l'équipe adverse était à 1,50
on peut se dire que faut parier 1,50 sur
l'a50 vous mettez 100 euros vous allez
toucher 150
la preuve que non des fois vaut mieux
mettre 2 euros sur l'islande vous ça
vous coûte que 2 euros si vous gagnez
vous gagnez 16 place maintenant aux
quarts de finale avec peut-être de
nouvelles surprises de l'islande ou du
pays de galles ce mercredi 29 juin leurs
codes s'élèvent respectivement à 7 50 et
5 25